the issues of voter fraud and voter
suppression have a long and tumultuous
history in the United States the
controversy is escalated in recent
months after Donald Trump and other
Republicans have repeatedly made claims
that there's rampant widespread voter
fraud in the United States of America
Trump is actually assembled a special
election integrity committee led by Vice
President Mike Pence and Kansas
secretary of state Kris Kobach one of
the most vocal Republicans calling for
tighter laws to prevent so-called voter
fraud even though he won the presidency
Trump seems obsessed with the idea that
the election was somehow rigged against
him Trump has repeatedly made the claim
that three to five million illegal
immigrants voted in the 2016
presidential election presumably for
Hillary Clinton a couple of weeks after
winning the election he tweeted in
addition to winning the electoral
college in a landslide I won the popular
vote if you deduct the millions of
people who voted illegally then in
February White House spokesperson
Stephen Miller was interviewed by George
Stephanopoulos and had this to say about
the issue of voter fraud and you have
14% of non-citizens
according to academic research at a
minimum are registered to vote
despite the over-the-top nature of
trumps claims a Republican claiming that
voter fraud harmed them in an election
is really nothing new before 2016 dozens
of states had already passed restrictive
voting laws ostensibly aimed at securing
so-called electoral integrity these
efforts were almost exclusively
spearheaded by Republicans who have long
been vocal about the supposed threat
that voter fraud poses to our democracy
so what's the truth even if Crump is
exaggerating is there still some reason
to be concerned about voter fraud
affecting our elections according to
every available study on the issue the
idea that voter fraud has any effect on
American elections whatsoever appears to
be a myth the scientific consensus on
voter fraud is clear as glass the
Brennan Center for Justice at
and why use law-school reviewed all
relevant literature on the subject and
put out a report called debunking the
voter fraud myth in January of this year
the report found that putting rhetoric
aside to look at the facts makes clear
that fraud by voters at the polls is
vanishingly rare and does not happen on
a scale even close to that necessary to
quote rigged an election a comprehensive
study published by a Columbia University
political science professor found that
number one voter fraud is extremely rare
number two a lack of evidence of voter
fraud is not because of a failure to
codify it and number three most voter
fraud allegations turn out to be
something other than fraud there's a
2016 paper from four Ivy League
professors and a Microsoft researcher
which concluded that the upper limit on
double voting in the 2012 election was
0.02 percent the upper limit the paper
noted that the incident rate was likely
much lower considering that the
researchers showed that quote many if
not all of these apparent double votes
could be a result of measurement error a
2016 analysis from Dartmouth found no
evidence of widespread voter fraud of
any kind a 2014 analysis from Harvard
found that quote the likely percent of
non citizen voters in recent US
elections is zero Richard L Hazen a law
professor at the University of
California Irvine and author of the
voting wars went back thirty years to
try to find a single example where quote
an election outcome could plausibly have
turned on voter impersonation fraud and
was unable to find one in one of the
most comprehensive investigations of
voter fraud to date Justin Levitt of
Loyola Law School was only able to
identify 31 credible allegations of
voter impersonation out of more than 1
billion ballots cast between 2000 and
2014
that's roughly point zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero three one percent of
votes which would be the result of
in-person voter fraud the figure may
actually be even lower according to
because he merely counted all credible
claims not prosecutions or convictions
voter impersonation is just one of
several tactics that can theoretically
be used to commit voter fraud Levitz
figure is an important one though
because the bulk of state laws aimed
preventing voter fraud are voter ID laws
which require registered voters to
provide government ID before casting a
ballot Levitt wrote in a 2014 op-ed in
the Washington Post that requirements to
show ID at the polls are designed for
pretty much one thing people showing up
at the polls pretending to be somebody
else in order to each cast one
incremental fake ballot this is a very
slow clunky and difficult way to steal
an election which is why it rarely
happens so essentially the voter ID law
is pushed by Republicans around the
country are totally ineffective in
stopping voter fraud and we'll get to
that in more detail later on Kansas
secretary of state Kris Kobach the man
who's now leading Donald Trump's voter
fraud crusade on a national level became
the only secretary of state in the
nation with the power to prosecute voter
fraud cases in 2015 after claiming that
quote there is a significant problem in
Kansas and in the rest of the country of
aliens getting on our voting rolls Kobuk
ultimately failed to prosecute a single
case of non-citizens committing voter
fraud Kobuk also examined 84 million
votes cast in 22 states to look for
cases of duplicate registration that
project yielded 14 prosecutions
representing point zero zero zero zero
one seven percent of the votes cast an
exhaustive Washington Post investigation
found only four documented cases of
voter fraud during the 2016 election
these included a trump supporter who
tried to vote twice in Iowa a trump
supporter who tried to vote twice in
Texas supposedly to quote test the
system and a woman who tried to cast a
ballot for a recently deceased spouse a
woman in Florida was also caught marking
empty bubbles on absentee ballots but
there's no evidence she changed
single presidential vote a 2017 analysis
from the Washington Post found that
there is quote no evidence to support
Trump's claims that people from
Massachusetts were bused in to New
Hampshire to vote against him and Kelly
Ayotte so where does all this hysteria
come from in the first place what if any
evidence do these conservatives have to
hold up in the face of the mountain of
evidence that seems to disprove their
claims earlier I showed you a clip of
White House spokesperson Stephen Miller
who told George Stephanopoulos that
quote 14% of non-citizens according to
academic research at a minimum are
registered to vote what academic
research was Stephen Miller referring to
turns out that Miller was referring to
research by Old Dominion University
professors that use data from the 2008
and 2010 elections now the Old Dominion
study didn't examine voter rolls or even
uncover any direct evidence of any
illegal immigrants voting but instead it
relied on voluntary polling data of
adult Hispanic Americans according to
the Old Dominion researchers 14 percent
of the survey several hundred
respondents who identified themselves as
non-citizens also said that they're
registered to vote the researchers then
extrapolated this finding to suggest
that there are potentially you know
millions of non-citizens lurking in the
shadows of our voter rolls casting
ballots that cancel out the franchise of
American citizens Stephen and Saleh
bahir a Harvard professor who manages
the data used in the Old Dominion study
said that the data was misused and the
study's conclusions are wrong and solid
bahir was adamant arguing that quote
their finding is entirely due to
measurement error adding that quote the
Old Dominion study is an incorrect use
of the survey that we manage and a false
claim of evidence of non citizen voting
it's a dangerous stray false fact and
solid bahir explained that quote we
asked people in successive years their
citizenship that minimizes the error
upon doing so we find
no instances of voting among people
stating consistently that they are
non-citizens even one of the Old
Dominion researchers Jesse Richmond said
to the Washington Post that quote there
has been a tendency to miss read our
results as proof of massive voter fraud
which we don't think they are so one of
the very researchers who Stephen Miller
cited says the data does not mean what
Miller claims it means a similar study
conducted by McLaughlin and Associates
in 2013 suggested that over 2 million
non-citizens may be registered to vote
in the US the study has been trotted out
by conservative publications like The
Washington Times and Infowars in a
desperate attempt to back up Trump and
Miller's claims about voter fraud but
the McLaughlin and Associates study
relies on the same flawed method as the
Old Dominion study quote cherry-picking
low frequency events in large sample
surveys as unsolvable here puts it and
as for Trump's outlandish claim that 3
to 5 million illegal aliens voted in the
2016 presidential election costing him
the popular vote can you guess where
that claim originated Infowars the
origin of trumps wacky claims can be
traced back to a Facebook post from Alex
Jones that reads quote 3 million votes
in the US presidential election were
cast by illegal aliens according to Greg
Phillips of the vote fraud dot-org
organization as it turns out however
there is no such report by vote fraud
org it doesn't exist Greg Phillips who
founded an organization called vote
stand said to PolitiFact that he's not
even affiliated with vote fraud org
rather the claims made by Infowars
correspond back to a series of since
deleted tweets from Phillips's account
from just after the November election on
November 11 Phillips tweeted completed
analysis of database of 180 million
voter registrations number of non
citizen votes exceeds 3 million
consulting legal team then on the 13th
of November he followed up with we have
verified more than 3 million votes cast
by non-citizens we are joining true the
votes to initiate legal action hashtag
unwritten little conservative that's
worked with the Alabama and Mississippi
Republican parties would not provide any
additional information to back up his
claims when confronted by PolitiFact
Phillips would also not say what the
data is or where it came from or what
methodology he used so we have no idea
how Phillips arrived at his conclusion
Phillips's only academic credentials are
a BS in business administration from the
University of Alabama
so Phillips is no expert in complex data
analytics and he clearly has an agenda
to try to show that voter fraud is a
major issue but nonetheless Phillips and
his claims have been taken seriously and
have been given a lot of attention by
some on the right Trump himself even
cited Phillips in January tweeting quote
look forward to seeing final results of
vote stand Greg Phillips and Cru say at
least three million votes were illegal
we must do better in response to
questions about the source of Crump's
three to five million illegal votes
claim then press secretary Sean Spicer
had this to say the President does
believe that he has stated that before I
think he stated his concerns voter fraud
and people voting illegally during the
campaign and he continues to maintain
that belief based on studies and
evidence that people have presented to
him Thank You Ryan today said there's no
evidence the National Association of
secretaries of state say that they don't
agree with the president's assessment
what evidence do you have as I said I
think the president has believed that
for a while based on studies information
he had presumably the supposed evidence
Spicer was referring to is Phillips's
November tweets and the corresponding
Infowars story as long as Phillips
refuses to release the data he's
referring to and defend its methodology
there is absolutely no reason to
consider his claims credible in all
likelihood Phillips probably used the
same flaw discredited method that the
Old Dominion professors used back in
2014 so again we're left with absolutely
no evidence that non-citizens vote in
meaningful numbers in a way that has any
impact on our elections the idea that
millions of illegal immigrants vote in
US elections makes no intuitive sense
either Wendy Weiser the director of the
democracy program at the Brennan Center
for Justice and Douglas Keith who's the
cat's fellow at the Brennan Center
explained in an op-ed for time that
quote it is relatively easy for a non
citizen to get caught if an ineligible
person intentionally registers or votes
not only do they risk being recognized
but their name will be on permanent
lists of voters for later detection and
as discussed below
lots of people scrutinized those lists
looking for potentially ineligible
voters they also add that quote even
more serious a non citizen can be
deported for casting a single vote they
were not eligible to cast for
non-citizens working towards
naturalization merely being registered
to vote can serve as a basis for denying
citizenship so again the idea that
millions or even thousands of
undocumented people in the US are
risking fines imprisonment and
deportation just to game the system and
cast one vote is preposterous but
Republicans play into the idea in an
effort to fearmonger to their base and
support not only their anti-immigration
agenda but also their politically
charged efforts to create tighter voting
restrictions and this is where the
really concerning aspect of this whole
issue comes into play the problem is
that the whole issue of voter fraud is
really a red herring it's a pretense
that Republicans have used for decades
to argue for voting restrictions such as
voter ID laws that ultimately serve to
disenfranchise significant portions of
vulnerable demographics that have been
shown to disproportionately vote for
Democrats the Brookings Institution
argued in a 2016 report that these voter
ID laws systematically disenfranchised
minorities young people and the poor
adding that they are only one of several
practices that add up to a widespread
effort at election discrimination
others include purges of the voting
rolls reductions in early voting
opportunities and the closing of polling
stations voter ID laws currently exist
in 20 states and the practices of
purging voter rolls in
early voting and the number of polling
stations is widespread throughout the
country in 2016 under the guise of
improving election integrity the
Republican dominated North Carolina
legislature enacted a voter ID law that
also eliminated same-day voter
registration and eliminated seven days
of early voting as well as putting an
end to out of precinct voting it was
struck down by a federal court which
found that the law had discriminatory
intent and that it targeted
african-americans with almost surgical
precision thousands of pages of
documents were released as part of the
case and some showed Republican
lawmakers specifically asking for data
sorted by race the judges noted that the
data that the North Carolina lawmakers
requested before crafting the law showed
that African Americans
disproportionately lacked the most
common kind of photo ID those issued by
the Department of Motor Vehicles the
data also showed that black voters were
more likely to make use of early voting
and that counties with Sunday voting in
2014 were disproportionately black and
Democratic after reviewing that data the
legislature passed the bill eliminating
early voting the judges wrote that thus
in what comes as close to a smoking gun
as we are likely to see in modern times
the states very justification for a
challenged statute hinges explicitly on
race specifically it's concerned that
African Americans who had overwhelmingly
voted for Democrats had too much access
to the franchise while governor pat
mccrory insisted that the North Carolina
laws only purpose was to combat voter
fraud longtime Republican consultant
Carter Wren who the Washington Post
described as a fixture in North Carolina
politics admitted that of course it's
political why else would you do it
look if African Americans voted
overwhelmingly Republican they would
have kept early voting right where it
was
Renne said it wasn't about
discriminating against African Americans
they just ended up in the middle of it
because they vote for Democrats these
racist voter restriction laws are a
completely insidious cowardly pathetic
shameful attempt by Republicans to
suppress the vote of vulnerable
demographics who won't vote for them
instead of going out and trying to
earn people's votes Republicans are
trying to shut them out of the ballot
box and robbed them of their right to
vote in the context of our country's
long and ugly history of barring people
of color from the ballot box the
discriminatory aspect of these voter
suppression laws is outright shameful
but even still the targeting of certain
demographics has not been exclusively
reserved for minorities students and
poor whites have also become the targets
of the Republican crusade to suppress
the vote in leaked emails Green Bay City
Clerk
Chris teske an appointee of Republican
mayor Jim Schmidt admitted that the city
was trying to hinder college students
from voting because they tend to vote
Democratic leaders of eight different
student groups at the University of
wisconsin-green Bay had asked the city
to put an early voting location on
campus to alleviate long lines which
prevented many students from voting in
the 2016 primaries the request was
denied and in an email to a colleague on
the matter Teske wrote I feel by asking
for this to be the site for early voting
is encouraging the students to vote more
than benefiting the city as a whole I
have heard it said that students lean
more toward the Democrats a lawsuit
filed in Alabama in 2015 cites the
example of a woman from a rural area who
can't vote because she lacks a driver's
license according to the lawsuit she
needs to get a state issued voter ID at
the DMV but the one nearest her is open
one day per month there's no public
transportation to another DMV 40 miles
away roundtrip with more opening hours
according to a study from NYU's Brennan
Center 11% of voting-age citizens
nationally lack necessary photo ID while
many people in rural areas have trouble
accessing ID offices just think of the
burden that these restrictions put on
people who lack the time and resources
necessary to acquire proper ID or the
countless people who were discouraged
from voting because of needlessly long
lines caused by local polling stations
being closed while voter fraud is a
phantom issue intentional voter
suppression at the hands of Republican
state officials is a very real danger
for many American
and now that Donald Trump is president
and Republicans control both houses of
Congress the concern about these voter
suppression efforts is only growing
Trump's election integrity commission
met for the first time on July 19th and
the Commission had previously requested
voting data from every state the kind of
data that the Commission requested is
the same kind of data North Carolina
lawmakers used to craft their racist
voter suppression legislation
considering all of the fear-mongering
about voter fraud coming from Trump and
other top Republicans many experts are
concerned that the Commission will use
the data to recommend similar measures
on the national level a number of states
initially refused the Commission's
request including Pennsylvania whose
Governor Tom wolf wrote a blistering
letter to Co Bach in response federal
courts can still for states like
Pennsylvania to comply with the
Commission's request any further voting
restrictions that could come out of
Trump's crusade could really be
devastating the u.s. already has an
abysmal voter turnout rate and American
democracy is already plagued by many
shortcomings far more serious than voter
fraud it sometimes feels like some
Americans think that the u.s. is the
only democratic country in the world and
we regularly pat ourselves on the back
for being such a free and fair society
we like to think that America is the
shining city on a hill that we have the
best democracy in the world but the
truth is the electoral integrity project
a nonprofit that monitors elections
around the world that is widely
considered the most reputable of such
organizations ranked the u.s. 50 second
out of 153 countries in the 2016
perceptions of electoral integrity index
quote displaying the worst performance
among equivalent Western democracies the
EPI cited some of the same voter
suppression tactics we've already gone
over as well as the practice of
gerrymandering as reasons for America's
poor rankings moreover the man who
created the criteria that the EPI uses
for grading elections Andrew Reynolds an
expert of international electoral
integrity and political science
professor at the University of North
Carolina found that North Carolina would
not even be classified as fully
functioning democracy if it were its own
country
the problem with American democracy is
not that we have too many people who are
voting who aren't supposed to it's that
we don't have enough participation in
our elections particularly from the
segments of society that the Republicans
are tactically trying to keep out of the
process just fifty five point four
percent of all eligible voters cast
ballots in 2016
compare that to the turnout and the
recent French elections where nearly
sixty eight percent of eligible citizens
voted and that was the worst turnout in
modern history the top countries in the
world like Belgium and Sweden have voter
turnouts
in the high 80 percents so we should be
embarrassed by the lack of democratic
participation in this country and we
should be doing everything we can to
make it easier for people to vote not
harder
the real threat to the integrity of
American democracy
has nothing to do with so-called illegal
aliens or dead people voting and it has
everything to do with conservatives
cowardly and in unamerican ways trying
to disenfranchise the most vulnerable
among us